high above castle is the bad park lil
hands her with it castle
for centuries it was home to the rulers
of Hessen castle
the hillside ensemble showcases
architectural and landscaping styles of
several different periods with an area
of more than two square kilometers the
man-made landscape is one of Europe's
largest mountainside parks in June 2013
it was designated a UNESCO World
Heritage Site
while the building's is an artificial
ruin the Levin book
the neo-gothic castle was built by
landgrave in hem in the late 18th
century when he died he was buried in
its Chapel
further up the hill is the emblem of the
city of castle the 70 meter high
hercules monument this is the starting
point of the baroque era cascades the
water started flowing in 1714
the masses of water are moved by the
natural gradient of the slope there are
no pumps instead an ingenious system of
reservoirs collects rainwater which runs
into the waterfalls it was designed by
Giovanni Francesco Genaro an architect
from Italy we have applied indiscernible
we still operate the system the way it
was originally conceived no modern
technical innovations have been added of
course
parts have been replaced like new valves
or pipes but we still have parts of the
old pipes that were laid by granny era
anti at all I don't enough for me so
part of the pipes are more than 300
years old and still work the holes in T
off my phone one 10 3
Valve's at every stage of the Cascades
have to be opened by hand
like here at the Steinhafel waterfall a
masterpiece of romantic garden design
dating from 1793
in a display lasting more than an hour
visitors follow the 350,000 liters of
water from the foot of the hercules
monument down the cascades to the lake
in front of the vill hems her castle
they're the accumulated water pressure
propels a geyser into the air for
several minutes
ever since the time of the land graves
of Hessen castle the gargantuan fountain
has provided the spectacular finish to
the Cascades at the vill hems through a
backpack
you